esta tarde mientras más de 40 países
junto con la onu intentaban recaudar 370
millones de dólares para ayudar a los
libaneses en la reconstrucción de beirut
las fuerzas de seguridad cargaron contra
grupos de manifestantes que canalizaron
su rabia arrojando piedras objetos que
encontraban a su paso mientras avanzaban
hacia el parlamento libanés los agentes
respondieron con una lluvia de gases
lacrimógenos y pelotas de goma para
disipar a la multitud que corría para no
ahogarse por los gases alrededor de 100
personas han resultado heridas la
mayoría han sido tratados en el lugar
por los paramédicos de la cruz roja pero
diez han tenido que ser llevados a los
hospitales los libaneses culpan a la
élite gobernante de la explosión y
quieren rendición de cuentas antes de la
conferencia internacional el presidente
manuel macrón ha criticado a la élite
política libanesa
diciendo que ha fallado al pueblo
libanés en la investigación
y que no ha podido formar gobierno un
requisito necesario para poder repartir
las ayudas internacionales